I can't forget I got to contact my high
school they want me there on the 25th of
October wow
yeah
do
okay we're ready to go there he's got
now good morning everybody
um we are right about 10:00 on the clock
on the other side of that wall in the
other office so with my military
background we want to start promptly at
the time we should um I'd like to
welcome everybody to today's uh
presentation uh this is a presentation
today that is coming forth from the task
force from Fred bronti uh dealing with
uh the Ed 306 uh rules minimum standards
for public school approval that are
being uh recommended uh to the uh State
Board of Education uh this is a
presentation many of us on this
committee right here uh Senator Ward to
my left and I sat together at the at a
recent presentation by Vermont Brad
branti at the conquer high school I know
others have done it similarly in other
locations in the state and we want to
thank you Fred for for having the
opportunity to come here today also of
visiting all these other locations when
they've been asking more for more
information on on the 306 so today I I
want to uh make it clear this is not a
public hearing this is a presentation
from the uh Fred uh Fred and his
committee there there's some committee
members task force members here as well
uh dealing with the 306 the rationale
and reasoning behind what we're doing
today is that we have a number of bills
uh which we've retained we've retained
20 bills in education here of which we
had over 100 and we have well over a
hundred coming at us for the next
session and it's it's an exhausting
process but of those which we retained
we've had a number of subcommittee
meetings and hearings and full uh
Committee of the whole uh meetings to
address these retained bills several of
those retained bills have linkage to uh
topics and subject areas which are in
the
306 and with that we're trying to find
out where we're going uh and how are we
going to react as a education committee
responsible for dealing with issues such
as mental health how are we going to
address that knowing that there might be
some changes or if there are changes
what do we have to do
statutorily so with that I don't want to
take much more time because we are
limited this morning we have a couple
hours here here uh I would would like to
uh recognize and and and welcome warmly
welcome Fred banti uh Fred and I met
years ago uh back in the Paul leather
days and in jenie Barry days and even a
little earlier uh when he came forth I I
believe it's Mary gu who was chairing
the committee at that time uh so uh
welcome Fred uh you're you're on board
here uh could you please help us and
understand a little bit more about uh
what's going on with 306 Rick is this is
this being live Streed yes yes this is
being live streamed um and we also have
our researcher here working with our
committee that's Jennifer 4 over on your
right over against the wall and so
yeah press the button y That's new
technology there all right I should know
first thanks a lot Rick for inviting me
I'm I'm really excited about this
opportunity to speak with all of you uh
my name is Fred banti um I want you to
know that I'm speaking here on uh behalf
of myself uh and on behalf of the
organization that I run the national
Center for Competency Based learning I'm
not speaking on behalf of the State
Board of Education or on behalf of the
Department of Education uh and
uh um and certainly some of the remarks
will be on behalf of of uh our
organization if you can just speak more
closely into the microphone having
trouble hearing I'm I'm sorry I will do
that okay thank
you uh I'm the past chair of the New
Hampshire State Board of Education and
current president of the national Center
for Competency Based learning on New
501c3 I started this organization when I
left the State Board of Education in
2013 after serving New Hampshire
students in public schools for what I've
been told is longer than anyone in State
history my goal today is that we begin a
process of uniting New Hampshire in a
nonpartisan commitment to create a new
day for public education in our great
state a day when school dropouts are a
thing of the past when the notion of
students getting a high school diploma
yet still having serious deficiency
genes in math and language arts is over
where students feel Joy in learning and
can't wait to get up in the morning to
learn where the word boring to describe
school is written about in history
books where we help put our students in
a position to earn their piece of the
American dream the day they leave our
system ready and prepared to contribute
to society their families their Futures
our state and our country that is the
promise of a competency based system
done
well you may say I'm a
dreamer I'm not the only one there needs
to be an extra effort on the part of all
stakehold holders in order to accomplish
this and I hope we start
today the traditional seat time model of
school did not work for me and my high
school I finished 206 6 out of 212
students I got rejected by every school
that I applied to school taught me that
I wasn't very bright life taught me that
school was wrong every day in America
7,000 students drop out of school this
is a national tragedy I've spent the
better part of my life trying to find a
better way to do school so that students
like me could be successful I went to
college to become a teacher and from
both colleges that I have earned degree
as a Bachelor of Science at Keen State
and a master's in education ational
leadership from Plymouth State I've been
honored with their alumni Achievement
Award Southern New Hampshire University
awarded me an honorary doctorate in
Competency Based learning I taught
eighth grade science for six years in
the Stanford Connecticut public schools
I chaired New Hampshire's assessment
steering committee that put together the
framework for the original state test
the state board's pioneering work on
Competency Based learning has been
supported by every Governor
since Republicans and
Democrats in 2005 we made New Hampshire
the first state in the United States to
put Competency Based learning into their
regulations today virtually every
state is now moving in the competency
Direction I have suggested that we put a
State Historical marker in front of lant
Hall to proudly show the physical
location of where the Nationwide
competency based movement
started this is my third time leading
this effort with the 306s my first time
was
1992 when I was appointed by Jud Greg
when Judy the was chairman of the State
Board of Education and Charlie Marson
was commissioner the second time was
when I was named chairman of the board
from 2003 to 2005 by Craig
Benson when Nick donu was
commissioner it was Craig Benson who
charged me with finding a new way to do
public education a charge that most
people would have run screaming away
from I was reappointed to the state
board by Governor Lynch I am proud that
my work has not been viewed as
partisan once again I've been asked to
use my three decades of experience with
this document to help lead our state to
a true Competency Based model in leading
this charge I put together a public
education an Allstar team that I could
not be more proud of some of the members
of that team are here with us today
Jackie Gillette is here Jackie Gillette
is former superintendent of Claremont
during the Claremont lawsuit days Jackie
is an education consultant and a member
board Nathan Harris is here Nate is a
former business executive in the medical
field and is currently pursuing a
doctorate in educational leadersh ship
at the University of New Hampshire with
a focus on Competency Based learning
Nate is also a member of the ncbl board
Val xan chuk is here Val is a former
chair of the Bia board current chair of
the New Hampshire learning initiative
Val runs a manufacturing company uh in
the Keen area called
graphicast in 2019 Val was named as one
of the top innovators in New
Hampshire Nate green is here name is for
Nate is formally uh chemistry teacher at
BO high school and part of the
leadership team at the department Nate
and I co-led this
effort we based our effort on advancing
Competency Based learning and the vision
of the State Board of Education written
in 2012 which states to harness
Community Resources and Technology to
provide a worldclass personalized
student- centered education in a
flexible Innovative learning environment
that promotes active engagement to
maximize the poal itial in every
individual the logic of a competency
based model is so simple and so obvious
that today as I said virtually every
state is moving in the competency
Direction here's how I have been
describing it for decades in the old
model the one that we are all familiar
with the constants are time and place
time 180 days time students Move On by
age Place Learning takes place inside
the walls of the school the variable is
learning some kids get A's B's C's D's
they still pass the course move on we
it make time and place the variable and
learning the constant we don't care the
state board made this statement in 2005
where learning happens we want to ensure
that it happens and at a high
level I tell students I've used this
example many times and it it's become
actually somewhat uh famous other people
starting to say it that in the old model
you could get an A in addition
subtraction
multiplication and a dnf and Division
and you still pass the
course if we believe that division is
important why should we let you pass the
course if you're going to learn to fly
an airplane you get an A in taking off
you get an A keeping a plane in the year
but you get a deer and F in landing they
don't let you pass the course so a
competency based model says you
demonstrate proficiency Mastery in all
of the required competencies and then
level while New Hampshire may be the
first state to embrace Competency Based
learning I believe that some states may
have even passed
us it is my hope and I believe that of
the department that we reclaim our
rightful position as the leader in the
competency based movement it is my
belief that we will accomplish this only
if we are working together which is why
I love that you invited me to speak here
today Rick because we have to do this
together there has to be an effort that
has the department working with the
legislature on important stuff like this
much are we willing to work together
this is you know that is Rick's
indication by doing this to May that
that uh that there is a desire to make
that happen but I believe for some that
the answer is
no New Hampshire has been traveling down
this path for nearly 20 years more than
any other state a path supported by
every Governor a truly non partisan
effort while we've made progress our
progress is substantially behind the
vision that was created in uh in
2007 uh shortly after the uh the state
board approved the regulations in 2005
this is this is the document my document
it's Fallen apart because I've used it
so much but this is the document that
was created in 2007 and when you read
this document this 2007 document there
was intended to be the spirit and the
intent behind the 2005 regulations you
see
go personally my opinion is that over
the past 20 years our department of
education has done not done enough to
support our schools in their efforts to
transform to a different model since
embarking on this Competency Based
Journey we still have largely a 20th
century system with increasing
sprinklings of a competency based model
on top how much longer do we need to
wait another 20
years we have kids falling through the
basis are we going to deprive
especially traditionally underserved
students with the promise of a
competency B Bas learning
system because the leadership in the
state dragged its
feet we can do this but we have to do it
together I'm convinced that House and
Senate education committees have the
potential to be a key Catalyst in
leading us to a great
place in a nonpartisan
way I'm asking the next question because
I truly don't know what the answer is
has uh Our House and Senate education
committees actually committed to moving
us to a true Competency Based system I I
don't know what the answer to that is
Rick whether you guys have done that
formally or
not I'm guessing that the answer is yes
be because based on Senate Bill uh
276 uh relative to Career Readiness and
career
credentials it sure seems like that's
the direction that that you guys are
moving in and it fits perfectly with
what we have been trying to
accomplish but to date I will tell you
that uh that our team has not
recommended putting into the um
regulations a graduation credit link to
Senate Bill 276 maybe that's something
that uh House and Senate education
committees would like to make a
recommendation on and my guess is that
the State Board of Education would
welcome uh something like that so I'm
I'm in hoping that there will be some uh
Fingerprints of of House and Senate um
on the ultimate uh uh plan that that uh
that gets uh passed into into uh uh
state regulations when the State Board
opens up uh rule making passes through
the 180 days and uh and um and moves on
in this in this H piece of legislation
ra regulations uh to make it make it
real so I would I would love to see that
the State Board of Education is by
Statute the board of directors for the
public schools in 2005 the board did its
job by establishing the direction it
believes our state needs to move in and
the whole country is following New
Hampshire's lead but what about here at
home is it possible that the slowness of
the pace of change is in no small part
because we have not brought together our
state leadership in this great
task As Americans we need to do this as
part of our patriotic Duty I am
convinced that America will not be the
economic winner of the 21st century if
we cannot get our public education act
together and watching the dis the
disarray in watching Washington is
discouraging China has more advanced
placement students than we have
students we can't afford to let kids
fall through the cracks we need to get
the best out of every student we will
get that if we have a United effort to
create a true Competency Based model a
model where every student believes that
they are learning for their own personal
benefit not for the benefit of the
teacher or the
school since first taking on this task a
couple of things have been made clear to
me first our public schools and our
educators are
stressed I've spoken in more than half
the States since we start started going
down this Competency Based path
preaching the Competency Based gospel
bragging about New Hampshire I've given
about 1500 presentations mostly in New
Hampshire public education is feeling
pressure from many directions well I
believe that public education in our
state is in better shape than in many
there is considerable fear and distrust
as a result of this trust this distrust
statements and accusations have been
made stoking that fear it has led to to
angry and inaccurate statements that are
not helpful one Organization leader said
that in this process feedback was
permitted by invitation
only that the rules have been worked on
mostly in secret and that quote
generally rules are developed through a
series of public meetings with public
input from all stakeholders that would
include teachers parents Educators Etc
end quote one would expect
that a statement like this from a leader
of a Statewide education group would be
individual I know that the statements
are highly inaccurate because I am the
most experienced person in the state
with regards to how these rules have
been reviewed in the last 30 years and
as promised this has been the most
inclusive process in the history of this
document the State Board of Education
is obliged to have one public hearing on
the
306s in 2005 his state board chair I
decided it would be better to hold
meetings on the 306s around the
state we held five face-to-face meetings
one in each
region then executive director of the
New Hampshire school boards Association
the late Ted comto referred to our
effort as the most inclusive in the
history of Education in New Hampshire a
couple of years later Mark Joyce then
executive director of the New Hampshire
school administrators Association in
testifying to the state board on a
hearing on special education said why
don't you run this process like you did
the minimum
standards despite that 2005 beyond the
Call of Duty effort I pledged we would
make this by far the most inclusive
process
ever in April of 2022 a year into our
work the 306 te presented at a session
of the school administrators Innovations
conference a conference open to all
Educators we've had 20 plus meetings
Zoom we held a two-day event with ASC
that included 40 to 50 content experts
mostly teachers we did something similar
to this in
2004 we told the school administrators
Association that we would have
information listening sessions in any
school district in the state that would
invite us I think that some doubted that
we would physically be able to do that
despite the fact that I had a serious
health issue in
2021 and after 2 years of coid team team
306 teammates Nate Harris Val ANUK and I
held sessions around the state in every
school district that invited us nearly
tripling the number of the 2005
sessions from all of these meetings with
various stakeholder groups one of our
most productive efforts has been working
with the school administrators
associations the school leaders who are
charged with implementation of the 306s
at the district level
the
nhsaa gave us a detailed list pages of
their concerns with our first
draft we have spent a lot of time with
their leadership and I believe that we
have satisfied their
concerns let me repeat that I believe
concerns I want to personally thank n
green of the department for his
fantastic work with Dr Mark mlan
executive director of the school
administrators Association who by the
way did his doctoral thesis on
Competency Based
learning if we have truly satisfied the
needs of the school administrators
Association some might
suggest there's a document that's ready
to go to the State Board of
Education but we're not there yet
and we're not stopping tomorrow we have
a working s uh session with longtime New
Hampshire
educator former do doe person who knows
this document as well as I anybody in
the state Christine Downing she is here
today and she has been Gathering input
from 100 to 200 teachers from around the
state and with ir Richardson from the
Nea leadership team who is a teacher of
teachers and who was asked to be on the
original 306 but
declined we're sitting down with them to
help us
synthesize the feedback from Christine
sessions and from our 40ish sessions
with various groups for possible
recommendations to the State Board SO
meetings in
five this time around 40
so when anybody says that this has not
been an inclusive process you can
constantly say to them and with numbers
to back it up that this has been the
most inclusive effort of the minimum
standards in the Department of Education
history by far and if anybody wants to
challenge me on that bring it
on but secondly and most importantly in
all of our face-to-face listening
sessions it's clear to Nate Harris Val
and myself
that New Hampshire Educators believe in
Competency Based
learning they want it done well they
want the department to do its job in
assisting the system and getting to that
new model and we couldn't agree with
them
more I can't promise you what the state
board will do with our
recommendations I believe that they will
say yes to
many so where do we go from here we
believe that this is a historic
opportunity in front of us if we do this
together it's an opportunity to create a
system of Education where we put joy in
the process of learning for every
student where we give students the
opportunity to play an important role in
the direction of their learning where we
raise the bar by redefining the high
school credit to mean achieving
proficiency with a bundling of related
competencies not just passing the course
with the c or a d and moving on
regardless of whether you're not you
actually learned
and by embedding minimum graduation
competencies required to earn a
diploma we want the notion of school to
be about the process of learning with
the entire Community playing a role in
the creating in
creating multiple learning
opportunities a new and better school
choice system inside the public
schools since we started going this down
this path in
2005 I've actually been
told by two private school leaders that
they are afraid of what we're
doing it's never been about whether our
teachers are doing a good job or not
they were asked to do their job in a bad
system A system that was not based on
learning but was based on seat time
where students moved on to the next
level regardless of whether or not they
actually
learned 20 years
now we've been at this no one's
expecting a flip of the switch but what
some of us are expecting is a concerted
nonpartisan all Hands-On deck effort to
make Competency Based learning a
together that's my thank you FR thank
you you mentioned some names as we were
passing through our history here Mark
Joyce Dr Joyce and I were born together
in County Hospital oh is that
right I had father was a great friend of
my uncle no kidding and and then going
down and talking B here my Lord Bal
you're you know the the person when it
comes to Career Technical education the
person when it comes time to recognize
the value of the those indicators within
our our uh requirements that for an for
an adequate education there's so much
out there and I appreciate what you're
doing Val and
Fred a quick question first Rick is it
possible for somebody to get me a water
sure Jen thank you thank uh before we
get into the this discussion and getting
into the some of these changes that we
see here on the side by side we have
with what we have now and what is being
proposed well over 100 Pages here um I
I'd like to you know just ask several
several questions which uh are floating
around one I developed as you were
discussing here uh we've had a number of
presentations through the state 40 plus
you said y um another other other
sources of gathering information where
what's the process got for us in the
future you mentioned that you're getting
together tomorrow yep with with folks
Christine and and herb and and Val and
and a few with um Val and um and uh Nate
Harris and Bob uh
mlin is there is there anybody else
joining us I think that that's I think
that's it thank you so much so Fred
going forward with that what is the
process that we're looking at there's a
lot of rumor and gossip going around
that these these uh proposed rules for
the minimum standards of public school
approval were going to go before the
board for approval um yesterday and I
heard that and I said no I and my call
to the department was no they're not
they're not on the docket for for quite
a while yeah uh so so the concern is
what are your steps next does does the
feedback and the information garnered at
all these hearings get compiled and does
it go back to your task force and they
make a recommendation or is it going
from their being compiled and and and
modifying based upon those and without
going back to the task force going
directly to the State Board saying
here's what we're recommending um Rick
would you would be okay um with Nick
green joining me invite any of the
members on your on that would you mind
coming
up um you know Nate Nate is our Mr
inside so um I think that on some of the
questions he might be better um he might
be are answering some of the questions
he's also our spreadsheet and analyst
and and works with us quite
frequently he's amazing and he did the
side by sides did a fantastic job um you
know so uh I'm window dressing Nate is
really the the guy who has done a great
job with this uh this uh whole effort
well everything was just shifted to you
Nate you're responsible no no
no uh yeah just for the record uh Dr n
green with the New Hampshire Department
of Education I'm the bureau
accountability I'll I'll answer the
question Rick so and and Nate please
chime in if uh if I if I left anything
out so what we're doing tomorrow um we
have um input from from those all those
sessions we've had we've got uh um uh
you know some some from some groups the
uh you know the Nea for example sent us
a um a formal uh document like the uh
like the school administrators did uh
there's some others that have done the
same thing sending us you know written
um uh written uh suggestions um so um in
in Nate's work and he can speak to it
better than than I can in Nate's work
with the school administrators as you
can imagine the school administrators
had many of the same concerns that were
expressed by other other groups and uh
so when we go through the um the
different recommendations from groups
many of those suggestions have already
been dealt with um in uh in uh Nate's
work with uh uh with the school
administrators uh and you know our our
two I mean we we all work with them um
but Nate you know Nate put the finishing
touches on it um so that is U that's
going to happen
tomorrow and um so we hope to get you
know we've got a couple hour session we
hope to get through a good bunch of that
hopefully most of it tomorrow um and we
need to get to uh Nate that information
by next uh Thursday I think it is Nate
yeah so I can talk a little bit about
the just sort of the process um um so I
know that the the State Board of
Education wants to be able to take a
look at the standards and start to have
their discussions around it um in order
to do that it has to be introduced as an
item with the state board so that they
can begin discussing it um our plan is
to take all of the feedback that we have
received both the feedback that has
already been incorporated into the draft
as well as any and all public feedback
that's been received by Fred his team or
has been sent to the department um all
that will be put together and provided
to the State Board of Education along
with the draft that is at the current
point when we've compiled all that
feedback together um as you can imagine
every time we receive a piece of
feedback and we take a look at the draft
it's constantly changing so we want to
make sure that you know we're not
providing just a a draft but also all
the feedback that has got along with
that
draft and and I would I would add to
that all the feedback that that the 306
team has said yes to I mean we uh at one
session we had uh I remember we had
someone say well can't we go back to the
old sage on the stage model and that's
not going to make it into the draft so
um so the you know the team uh uh will
uh assess um the the uh feedback from
various organizations and make a
decision which uh which are the ones
that we want to actually pass forward
for consideration to the State Board it
so what I'm gleaning from all this is
that the draft will be submitted to the
State
Board there's a feedback package here
that's not part of the
draft that's going to go to the state
board at this point in time yes so then
the task force itself is done their
job in essence I I believe that that you
know to be the case I mean to me it's
the task force has done its job the uh
um my guess is that the commissioner and
the department will in the State Board
will probably ask me
to stick around through the process for
assistance whenever whenever I can help
and and just so that everybody you know
gets a a decent timeline on this so
we're looking at getting something to
them for their November state board
meeting
and um and and if we are successful
doing that which I I hope we will be um
then uh then it's it's uh whether the
State Board takes any action on that or
not I'm not sure do you know whether the
state board will take action on that or
not
Nate so just like any set of Ru making
um if the State Board takes any action
it kicks off a specific timeline that
the state board has to follow um so I
know that they want to begin publicly
discussing the rules um but you know
it's not something where a draft can be
presented and the State Board votes and
approves the draft there's a full rul
making process that would end up being
kicked off by that um and I I would
probably Echo what Fred said my guess is
the stateboard is going to want to have
conversations like this one as well with
members of the task force and with Fred
as part of that um but there will also
be public hearings at the State Board
holds as well then then Fred and Nate
are there any changes within this
package that I haven't
omy that are contrary or different from
statutory law that exists right now
other words you're going to have to take
the package after from the state board
to jail car yes they're going to say is
there statutory language which supports
what you're propos what you're proposing
to
us is for example definitions have they
changed and have they changed how are
you going to uh explain that to Jael car
when the statute says something
contrary that's so that's something
that sorry I didn't realiz button didn't
get hit there um yeah so that that's
part of the rle making process um we
tend to have a number of discussions
with Jael car um particularly something
of this magnitude um when you're talking
about a large number of changes my guess
is there will be you know a decent
amount of back and forth with Jael car
specific to definitions one of the
reasons why there's a little bit of uh
timeline on this now is um any any rules
have expiration dates on them um
different parts of the 306s over the
last 20 years have been changed and
edited and adopted at different times
and parts of those rules are coming to
their expiration dates some of them have
recently expired the definition section
being one of those so right now that
definition sections in the 306s has
actually expired and isn't in that um
isn't in the current draft so we need to
move forward with some of these sections
because we're hitting up against some
deadlines right now with rule expiration
dates yes and we've been through that
before yes
yes so thank you for being here this
morning so the clarification uh Dr
Green the the State Board receives the
report at some point in time perhaps in
November does a board then work on the
redrafting or looking at uh the multiple
input sessions that have come out that's
not that does not start the 180 day
timeline the as I understand it it's
when the board accepts the report that
the actual 180 day timeline if that be
the case then are you saying that the
there's going to be some time frame
within which the State Board is going to
work on the document first before the
180 days timeline start is that
correct that would certainly be within
their purview yes um I haven't had any
specific conversation with the the state
board or the board chair as to whether
they have a a timeline for when they
want to work on the rules I know they
want each of the state board members
want to take a look at the draft um but
I don't know what timeline they're
looking at for their work sessions
versus when they look at starting it as
that official rulem process so we're
we're still unclear then exactly when
the 180 days would actually start then
is that correct correct okay thank you
as as I understand it and you correct me
if I'm wrong the state board will uh
will actually officially vote to enter
Ru
making is that isn't that the way that
it
works
so that if they did that that would
start the clock right yes right okay I'm
gonna I whether that happens you whether
that happens in
November I don't and then I'm going to
turn it over to Senator Waters with us
too or other members of the committee
I'd recognize of course Senator first
but one of the reasons why we um asked
that you present here today is that we
are dealing with three bills this
afternoon dealing with mental health and
when I look at the Ed rules
30640 it identifies health health
education and within that there
subcategories underneath that one of
which is mental health in the proposed
rules I'm seeing all those elements
within underneath these categories such
as Career Technical
education uh mathematics social studies
Etc being
eliminated so then then we're concerned
that what is part of Health how do we
write AC how are academic standards
going to be developed how are the old
curriculum Frameworks going to be
written to incorporate those academic
standards now this is different than the
minim Public School standards for
approval which the state board has a
responsibility for but we have concerns
36.4 then what kind of statutory
reference do we have to support uh the
teaching of that in the schools so that
was from an earlier draft um I want to
say several months ago all the program
standards that are in the back now
starting from I think right around 3063
going through to the end um I think the
last one was Holocaust and genocide
studies all those program um areas are
um still in the current draft of the
rules and they haven't been
changed that's refreshing to hear so all
those subject areas would the elements
within remain intact yes the only thing
that has been changed is there are four
or five of the subject areas that called
out specific areas of assessment and we
have a section within the 306 rules that
also calls out assessment there were
some redundancies in those sections so
what we did was we expanded the section
in the 306s on assessment and then in
each of the subject areas we refer to
that particular assessment subject that
says when you are assessing students you
need to follow all of the regulations
that exist within uh and I believe it's
3062 now um these assessment areas so
essentially that way you're not looking
at you know the business education rules
with one set of assessment requirements
in English with a different set of
assessment requirements math with a
different set of assessment requirements
we tried to take all of that and make
one expansive assessment
section thank you I I want to also say
that uh
that we tried to communicate with
virtually everybody um that if you have
I mean because our you know our team is
not a a team of specialists in an area
like mental health that you're talking
about Rick uh and so many of the other
areas and we tried to to talk to uh any
group that would that would have
interest in talking to us about uh do
they have specific things that they
would like uh to uh us to address in the
minimum standards and we were and we did
connect with a number of them and we
have uh information recommendations from
a number of specific uh organizations um
that that uh that's on our shopping list
tomorrow to go over and uh and and see
about what we uh recommend to the State
Board in these subject areas were real
concerned when you send teams out from
the Department to assess whether the
schools are meeting the minimum
standards for public school approval
with these elements within those subject
areas currently there it's an area which
can be asked what are you doing about
this Mr School in in ensuring that
you're addressing this topic without
them there then there it's raised
considerable concern amongst this
committee right
here yeah so within the next two weeks
my office is releasing the uh new ibas
survey this is the input based
accountability uh survey that's in
statute and that refers directly to
those sections of the Ed 300s or the
e306 so for example when principles go
in to complete the ibass survey it's
going to say you know do you have a
mathematics program that is consistent
with
ed360 and they'll go in and they're
going to see those program standards
they referring to and so when we talk
about you know um whether schools are
beating an adequate education for those
program standards that's what the ibass
is attached to it's attached directly to
those program standards at the end of
the
anything just a couple of
comments I just took a look at the
reading and math scor and science course
this morning and they are dismal and I
just think that for a state New
Hampshire we have to do much
better there's also an article about the
children trying to enter college and
colleges have to be prepared to have a
year of remedial instruction in order
for these kids to be able to progress
and eventually get their college
degree this past weekend I ATT attended
a conference on education and Workforce
Development and one of the speakers said
that we had a very good educational
program last century and he said for us
to try to keep those same standards now
100 years later is totally wrong we have
to do something we have to get our kids
prepared for the time that we live in
right
now I totally agree um here's what I
would say
once again and it's somewhat repeating
what I said earlier but in this this old
model that was created in essence in
1906 at a conference in Harvard um that
uh started this system based on what we
call the Carnegie unit that was based on
time it was not based on learning and uh
it was in in many ways a sorting
mechanism to figure out which kids they
thought were smart enough to go to
college and other kids will just send
them into the workplace or into the
military and it really did not assure uh
learning in in a competency based model
if we're doing a real Competency Based
model then you don't move on until you
demonstrate that you have actually
learned and um and and and that learning
if you're doing it if if our schools are
doing it right is not is not about you
can pass the test on Friday and then you
forget it two weeks later it's about
truly
mastering um the uh becoming proficient
in whatever the required competencies
are and that means that you can use that
information in known and unknown
situations in the future and we're
clearly demonstrating for our colleges
that they they are accepting these uh uh
students that they see on their uh
report cards or their transcripts that
they've gotten certain skills and when
they get to College they find out it's
not quite it's not quite the case and uh
that uh that they actually haven't um
they haven't learned what they needed to
learn so so in I think in a true
Competency Based
model that if we do this job right uh I
believe that this is this is going to be
a new day for
Education okay I I'd like to open this
up to the committee right there there's
issues which we want to discuss District
competencies graduation competencies
proficiency Mastery all these terms
which are within repan
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much Mr Bon uh Dr Green uh and
others from uh from the the 306 team
that uh that are joining us this morning
appreciate all the work that you've done
um my um not not not withstanding the uh
the Senator's comment with respect to
student performance you you know I've
always felt proud particularly uh 12
years you know on a on a local school
board and now serving on the education
committee that New Hampshire students
overall perform among the best in the
country I'm talking about New
Hampshire's public school students
performing among the best in the country
normally top five or six you know in the
you know of all the of all the uh 50
states and um uh but uh but it's also uh
really uh really glaring to me uh um and
to I think many uh many people across
the state um and uh and especially came
uh uh came out during the work we did on
with the school funding commission that
that Val ANUK and and Mel and Rick also
and Karine uh served on um that uh that
you know this this strong student
performance doesn't exist everywhere and
uh uh where I live in Hopkinson where I
served on the board for 12 years our
average student performance I think is
in the 80th percentile Statewide which
is obviously above State average but you
only have to go 15 20 minutes up the
road up to Newport and the average
student performance there is in the
fourth percentile which um which in a
lot of I mean that I don't think is
anything that any school district would
want to brag about but um but when you
take a look at at um you know um despite
just being 152 minutes uh you know up
the road uh you take a look at those two
communities and they're both very
different in terms of the socioeconomic
um uh capacities of those communities so
Hopkinson supports a strong school
school budget a strong uh uh per student
uh cost and um and we've got we've got
pretty high property taxes to do it you
go up to
Newport not so strong a school budget
not so strong per student cost but super
high property taxes they're working
Beyond harder than we're working in
Hopkinson uh and what are they getting
for it they're getting an average fourth
percentile um you know student outcome
and um and so so you know so I think
when we take a look at student
performance across the state there's a
lot of factors that that go into it and
uh and certainly the uh the minimum
standards would be one of those factors
among a lot of different factors that
play into uh to how well um students
learn but the question that I have for
for uh for you is really more um more
process oriented along the lines of what
Rick was um what you know started
started in on I think uh um I think Rick
would probably get to this question too
but um but under the the
section uh of law that uh that defines
the substit of educational content of an
adequate education which the 306s lean
on to um um you know as part of the
rulemaking process
in um in uh Roman 4 of that where it
talks about the minimum standards for
public school approval one of the um one
of the the provisions in statute states
that that the State Board shall not
amend any existing academic standards
and shall not approve any new academic
standards without the prior review and
recommendation of the legislative
oversight committee established in 193
uh C colon 8A which uh representative
llad is the the chair of and um and I
serve on on that so so my question is um
is prior to the state
board's approval of any proposed rule
changes and beginning this 180-day clock
uh what is the board's plan for bringing
these before the legislative oversight
committee so I I can say that I've uh
spoken several times with uh Department
attorneys regarding that particular
provision and what the process will be
for noticing the oversight committee
when the board gets to that point um I
think there needs to be some kind of
formal process for when the board starts
theirs and then sends a notice directly
to the oversight committee um exactly
how that works or what the notice will
look like um I'm not sure about but it
is something that you know has has been
discussed um and I've brought it up with
our Attorneys at the department to make
sure that that process moves forward so
ju just a follow up and thank you very
much Dr Green for that um
so would that take place prior to the
approval um of the rules and the 180 day
clock you know jail car clock or would
it would it take place prior to uh to
that maybe after the board has seen the
rules and then prior to acting on them
so where it starts I'm not entirely sure
but I think it would have to occur it
would have to occur before any kind of
approval move forward or before anything
would be able to be sent to Jael car and
work done with OS because I think there
needs to be some simultaneous processes
going on there where you need both the
approval of that oversight Committee of
any revisions to the standards as well
as the approval from the state board um
I haven't been involved in in what that
process looks like in working with both
the state board and the oversight
committee um which is part of why I sort
of punted that over to the attorneys to
say you know there's a legal process
here that needs to be figured out
because it's in statute right y no I
appreciate that and so I I would
appreciate if if uh this committee could
could maybe receive some some
um you know U information on on not not
looking at the on the day it would
happen but in terms of the timeline the
process yeah timeline prior to the 180
day plot starting that that the
oversight committee would be presented
uh and given the opportunity that it is
entitled to uh statute to review and
recommend um
U any changes to
rules thank you very much just interject
on that one uh the as I spoke with
representative Miler and Luna this
morning the next step for this committee
would to throw the ball to the
legislative oversight committee and we
will be in contact with you regarding
that further represent Myer thank you Mr
chair I've got uh a question and a
statement uh Dr Green when did you say
that the new draft is going to be
available uh so we're looking at the
November no thank you uh we're looking
at the November state board meeting um
it's always the second Thursday of the
month I believe that's November 9th so
that's when the new draft will be
available for those of us to look at it
then yes yep and all of the public
feedback as well because that would all
be uh anything that we submit to the
State Board of Education becomes a
public document so that's available as
part of their agenda and materials yeah
my statement is kind of tough that I'm
about to make I've been on this
committee for 12 years and in the prior
administrations there has been a
concerted effort to work with school the
school Community to create uh the new
draft Etc when these every 10 years when
these come up you need to know that
there are some of us that do not have a
trust in the Department of
Education uh it has not uh frankly the
leadership has not reached out in the
past to school leaders to teachers it's
been pretty much single
Dimension I know Fred has tried to
engage more and more people so the
concern that I have frankly is that uh
when the public statements get put into
this document what the state board will
do because frankly the state board has
not listened to the volume of voices
that have been there in its presence and
some of the decisions frankly most of
the decisions they've made have been
contrary to those who work in public
schools on a day-to-day basis
representative Miler I want to be very
careful here because this is an issue
we're dealing with the the group the
task force and what they're submitting
to the State Board of Education not to
the department I understand that and my
my my point is that I want to make sure
the department and understands that
there are people out here that are
watching this very
carefully and the response that the
department has to this recommendation
that's coming from this committee is
going to be sorely looked at and
hopefully that the history that the
department has will not continue and
will take the input from the community
and from the various groups seriously in
a way they haven't in the
past once again we this has gone on the
road for 40 type presentations plus
working groups um I recognize that in
being at one of those hearings at
conquered High School I saw folks saying
we have a concern here here or there uh
I am just hoping that those
recommendations will go forward as
you've mentioned they would uh and it'
be good if it went back to the task
force too and so the final draft that
goes to the State Board would be from
the task force not from some on the task
force but all the task force or by a
vote of the task force I think that
would be a wonderful thing to happen
let's take some of the time we have
remaining here because there's another
hour here to really get down into and
can we have a brief discussion uh Fred
on some of the issues that you know
alluded to the the definitions of
Competency proficiency what is the
minimum you know minimum bar that we're
going to have to say that a person is
competent is that going to be discussed
and decided by the local school
district uh in terms of or is it going
to be as a direct result of the
Statewide assessment and where they show
up on that um and which we don't give to
all these subject areas and we're going
to have uh these standards applicable to
areas such as health uh so what how does
a district know how to define what that
bar is for a graduation competency for a
district competency and also to be
aligned with our academic
standards so um one of the things that I
think is one of the more significant
changes in the document and and this was
uh
really
um pushed pretty hard by the school
administrators Association to have a set
of graduation competencies what does it
mean to graduate from a New Hampshire
High
School and so what our team did led by
Brian stack who was then the principal
of of sanbor Regional High School and
David Ryan who was the superintendent of
schools in in
exor is they looked at at
um um at different uh standards
competencies uh from a number of states
and they
drafted a a grouping of of
competencies um for uh uh Broken Out In
by subject area so from a math
standpoint they had a set uh when you
know we had a uh Nate ran it but we had
a two-day session uh in lonia lonia
middle school with 40 to 50 content
experts we wanted to show them because
they're the experts not us we wanted to
show them what we had come up with and
um and I spoke to them uh and I and I
said to them okay so we're you know we
we've put these together for you to look
at as a draft um and uh but you know but
you tell us uh you know are these the
right ones that need to be changed you
know whatever you are think that they
should look like we're very interested
seeing that and and I I made the
recommendation to them that that they
can't look at that set of Standards at
that set of
competencies um in an aspirational way
where gee we'd love it if every kid did
this because we're saying these are the
graduation competencies here is a bar by
which we want every single graduate from
a New Hampshire High School to get over
in math in language arts in whatever uh
and you can't set it so
low that it becomes a joke so what is
that sweet spot that we are willing to
say this is what a New Hampshire
graduate uh knows and is able to do this
is the minimum of what a New Hampshire
graduate knows and be able is able to do
uh my sense is that that is a raising of
the bar that alone is a raising of the
bar because I guarantee we've had kids
that have graduated from high school not
just in New Hampshire but all over the
country that uh that have been you know
not meeting some important uh areas you
know you raised the subject earlier
about
you know about the the huge amount of of
kids that uh go to college and have to
take remedial math and or language arts
because they didn't get uh you know the
the transcript said that they learned um
but they really didn't so so this alone
to me is one of those one of the things
that has been put into the document that
we hope and and the school
administrators were strong about this um
the uh uh the commissioner had
recommended let's put it in a side
document let's put these in a side
document so we were looking at that for
a while the superintendent came back and
said if you put it in the side document
they won't pay enough attention to it
it's got to be in the 306s and that in
our team the 306 team was like we kind
of agree with the superintendent so we
went back and forth and ultimately it's
in the document so um so that is that is
one of those things that I think is
important in
definitions on we put on definitions of
Competency Based
learning this the this was actually from
Mark mlan um uh he said why don't you
put the definition from the Aurora
Institute which is um the organization
recognized around the country as you
know either the leader or one of the the
the leaders in the um in Competency
Based learning why don't you put their
definition under you know uh in you know
in the definition section for for uh
Competency Based letter so that's what
we did we put that in so it's becoming
it's it's clear it's going to be clear
to everybody this is the direction this
is where we're going so we did have um a
bit of an arm wrestle
on should we continue to use the word
Mastery or should we we use the word
proficiency
instead and I think our team felt that
that the education Community would like
the word proficiency better than the
word
Mastery um and we we made the change in
you know in in the draft and um and we
defined proficiency as a minimum level
of
Mastery and um when we've kind of
marched it around to in the listening
sessions we really didn't get a lot of
support for it I mean it was kind of
like a six and one and a half a dozen or
the other I don't think that that a
whole lot of people cared I you know so
I'm not sure where that one ultimately
ends up um so
um th those were the ones that that I I
thought you were addressing but I I'll
gladly address any other stuff that uh
that you want that I think are are
significant elements of the minimum
standards
are there any questions from
representative
cordelli thank you Mr chairman thank you
thank you all for being here the whole
task force um to follow up on the
graduation requirements um so um the
recommendation will be part of the draft
that you present on um November 9th I
take it um to follow up on that um you
really didn't get push back on
it out you know it was like that you
know that was not a we got pushed back
on some things we got pushed back on a
number of things as you know as anybody
Rick or or Mel or or Dave and you guys
actually came to sessions and so you saw
it was push back so we got a whole bunch
of things we got push back on that was
not one of them right I was just curious
about that because we often talk about
local control and all and I'm wondering
how local school districts will feel to
a state set of graduation competencies
because we've we've had legislation last
year and will again this year about
early graduation and what what is the
bar how do you measure to allow someone
for early graduation U but I guess this
minimum set of uh State competencies
would accomplish
that I I you know again the the
superintendent felt strongly that that
that when are we going to finally
say that if you are a graduate from a
New Hampshire High School that this is
what you know and are able to do when
are we going to say that because because
we've got um in in essence uh a hundred
different um school districts
saus um that that could have aspirations
all over the place and um are you know
we are the state are we you know are are
are we acting um as a
team philosophically in where we are
going it doesn't mean that everybody's
doing you know how anybody gets there
that's their job that you know for the
local leaders to figure out what it is
that uh that that uh um that that they
are going to do in order to make sure
that they get their kids uh over that
line so um so uh you know I feel good
about is it possible that um we set
those standards and um and and give
flexibility to school districts if they
want to alter it then uh you know then
they have the opportunity well that's a
I mean it's a thought that uh that
certainly makes it possible for
something like that thank you just
wondering also how do you envision
moving towards a system like that of
having a state um minimum set of
graduation requirements what is the
process timeline for moving to uh
something um that's considerably
different than what we do now I think
generally speaking that the that the
school dist that the school leaders are
going to like it I mean that is the
impression that I got that from you know
from working with them so um you know I
don't know that that you know I said
earlier that um you know that uh our
education Community has bought in I am
absolutely convinced they have bought
into Competency Based learning they want
to do it right they want to do it well
and they want the State Department of
Education to do um the best job possible
in assisting them in getting to the
place that they that they feel that they
need to go so um so uh it it it it is
it's going to take work I believe that
you know and I I'd like to have Nate
speak to this uh a bit because I believe
that the department gets it that they're
going to have to do um they're going to
have to do more to um assist districts
in moving in the direction that we're
trying to go which in in in reality is
not any different than the direction in
2005 we are not trying to move it in a
different direction you read this um
this document and you know I had you
know because I'm a packrat I I happen to
have a bunch of copies of this left over
in sitting in my closet when we first
put the team together I sent everybody a
physical copy of it and then asked them
to read the key 21 pages and get back to
me with their thoughts and uh it was Val
that said it said you know you could
really take the 2007 date off of this
document put in
2021 and it's largely the same thing
we're trying to accomplish so this is so
it's not new in the sense that we are
handing them this new goal this new
Direction no it's the same direction
that the state has been trying to go in
for 20 years so it's so to me I just sit
there and say okay 20 years went by like
that is another 20 years going to go by
like that are we still going to have
kids falling through the cracks still
getting grades C's and DS and passing
and still not knowing um what they
should know to to to earn that New
Hampshire diploma I mean at some point
in time all of us have to say we're GNA
build the best Competency Based model we
can we're going to do this as a team and
and that team is and we're not talking
about forcing up anything upon anybody
we're talking about we get the New
Hampshire Community Education Community
together I believe that their leadership
wants this as bad as any of us do and
and they want and they want Flex ility
and how they get there and so I think
you know I I am feeling good about where
we are right now especially with the uh
um with the way that talks have been
going with the school administrators
Association Nate do you want to add
anything to that yeah I think regardless
of you know any of the changes that go
into the minimum standards one of the
things that we recognize that my team
recognizes of the department is you know
there are things that we need to be
doing better at we need to be doing
better at communication directly with
the field and with schools we need to be
providing more direct technical
assistance and support uh you know when
representative luno talks about the
differences in Hopkinton in Newport we
see that in the data at the department
as well and what we can be doing more of
is looking at where we're putting our
resources as a department you know it
doesn't necessarily need to be that
we're providing the exact same level of
support to every school and District but
what are the schools and districts that
need more support and how do we get the
resources from the Department into those
schools and working directly with those
teachers with those School leaders um so
I see any kind of changes in the minimum
standards as you know once we get to
that point once we're through the whole
process you know what gets approved by
the state board we have to be able to
provide support and technical assistance
directly to schools on what those rules
are and how they're being implemented
and it has to be a partnership between
the department and the schools to get it
done further questions yes represent
Ellison uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for picking my question uh during all of
the discuss Russians uh with the task
force has there been any any attention
paid to fisical capacity here I we're
talking about the department want will
have to do more we'll probably need more
people to do more uh I think local
school districts uh in terms of changing
will have to do more and that there's a
fiscal implication here and I I it may
not be under the purview of the tax
supposed to deal with that but it would
seem to me that that shortly very
shortly we're going to be looking at a
at a dollar side and we'll go from there
and as you are aware the the dollars uh
are scarce uh but I'm just wondering was
there any cons is there any
consideration about that uh first of all
I want to apologize because I was about
to say well you know art but then I I
recognized that you know I said I said
Rick and Dave and Mel like I apologize I
I I I I should be saying representative
luno and representative Miler so anyway
my my error and so so representative
Ellison I will say that um we did have
conversations about capacity about money
um uh one of the things that we did that
got rejected which we did on this is
interesting we did it on purpose purpose
okay we we actually sent something to
the department that we knew was going to
get
rejected and that was um
counselors and we
knew they're going to say no I mean they
have no choice it's an unfunded mandate
and and um but all of us our team wanted
to make the statement
that that you know that standard was
probably created in the
80s and when we look at the state of
mental health that you were talking
about earlier rck I'm sorry
representative flat um that that um that
um drug issues so many you know so many
issues that are are our uh kids are
dealing with these days that it's
the load on Guidance just seemed like
it's it's not right
so we we we sent a recommendation over
knowing full well no one was all upset
on our end we knew it was going to
happen so it got rejected we also had um
we also put into the document something
that I'm really upset that would that is
going to get taken out and that is um or
maybe already has been taken out the the
idea of personalized learning plans we
wanted personalized learning
plans and uh the uh School
administrators all pretty much said you
know nice idea but you know but it's
it's not a flip of a switch that this is
not that easy to do and there have been
some states that actually have gone down
that road and done it successfully and
others that have not been successful at
it so the school admin ministrators
agreed that once we're past the uh the
minimum standards that we get together
and have a Statewide conversation on how
do we do personalized learning
plans just I want to correct a little
bit of that not that the department
rejected it but there are several ideas
that were put forward as part of the
minimum standards and then the
department did a fiscal analysis of what
it would cost districts to put that into
the minimum standards and then it
couldn't move for without some plan for
them providing for schools to be able to
provide for those costs um and it's not
within the purview of this task force to
be able to raise and appropriate funds
for schools so I just I want to correct
that the department did not reject it
but recognize that some of the ideas to
be put forward would have um had a price
tag of a few million dollars and that
recommending that without also
recommending a process by which schools
could raise those funds um was not part
of what this task force could do okay
I'd like to just interject here a little
bit um I've been down this road in
education myself as a as a school
teacher as a school administrator
principal um I can remember when we had
to teach the difference to a fourth
grade Stu student the difference between
a number and a
numeral they didn't know and you know
that wasn't our primary interest in in
teaching mathematics and getting these
competencies
across and I have a real concern and we
we also have had IEPs and IPS individual
plans teachers became managers of paper
and less time in a classroom
teaching so that and I'm sure represent
Myer will agree in that they we that
dropped by seeing that it was uh not a
really efficient use of teaching
instruction in the
classroom so my concern still lies with
these
competencies um we've had competenc se's
written in statute for many years
now and we do know that there are some
students that move from one school to
another they have taken a course in the
previous school but it's not in the
scope and sequence of curriculum
offerings in the receiving school
they're made to take the course again
they don't have the opp option of taking
a as they should according to your rules
there's 43 courses each school is
supposed to have have high schoolwise
they're supposed to have competency
assessments to determine that do schools
have this in place or is it something
that just hasn't happened um and you
know some are doing it I've been to some
schools in the state where they're
they're on board they're doing this and
it's working other schools are not so
what's being done to make those schools
that are not accountable for what we
already have in
statute so I think the times where we've
seen that have been really when a
student has taken a course at VX this
tends to be the most common thing and
then they bring that course back to say
their their um public resident District
that they might be attending I know and
I believe it was not last year but two
years ago there was a statute that was
passed that required schools to accept
the credits from any other approved
School within the state of New Hampshire
um since the passage of that statute my
office hasn't received any uh complaints
of that occurring with students I'm not
saying it's not occurring but we were
seeing a frequency of complaints prior
to the passage to that statute and since
then we haven't seen that we saw Val and
I saw it on the crew technical education
where a student couldn't go to a CTE
class simply because that one math or
one science course was offered at the
same time and even though the courses
are the program they were enrolled in at
the CTE taught the same
competencies that we finally got
something done where there's an
agreement between the the sending and
the receiving but uh it's
it's it's uh I I fear that we have some
schools that don't have these compass in
place for the kid that moves into town
and said I took Algebra 1 in junior high
school because I had pre pre-algebra in
the sixth grade that's occurring in
places in our country today but you get
to that receiving school oh no we only
teach Algebra 1 to our
freshmen if you take it in the junior
high school or middle school level
you're math immature and you're not
going to get it uh so uh there there's
some issues I think we have to do in
order to get these these District
competencies in place with what the
competencies are that we're looking
these minimum targets what you're
talking about here for
proficiency uh absolutely and and I
think really what what I see you
describing is a 20th century system and
you know in a in a 20 first century
system we should that student should be
able to in any in any way
uh prove that he or she has uh is
proficient in those competencies and be
done they should not have to you know
they should not have to be forced to go
back in and do a course all over again
and and and if and if uh they're missing
uh let's say that there are a handful of
competencies that are required for a
particular course and they're clearly
proficient in in four out of the five of
them well they should not have to go do
the the whole course they should they
should I I have no problem with the
school saying you know we're not giving
credit until we know that you're
proficient in all of them and so you can
do vac we can you know here's a here's a
number of ways that we can approach the
the deficiency and ensure that the the
uh
student gets where they need to go in an
efficient manner so um I think that you
know some of those same frustrations
uh lots of people have about uh the
deficiencies of the old model but I
think in a competency based model if
it's done well that stuff should be
addressed did your did your group
address the issue then do the schools
have in place a
competency assessment or review to to
decide yeah they got these four but
they're missing this fifth one um so we
can make that fifth one up and you'll
get credit for this course do they have
the competenc Assessments in place to
work so there there are requirements
within the 306s that require districts
to either have a locally developed
assessment of those competencies or be
able to lean on state approved
assessments of competencies the addition
of the state approved assessments was
something that I believe was added in
just in the last couple of years and so
the stateboard has looked at um or plans
to look at some national uh types of
assessments things like assessments
through college board and AP assessments
through ETS or practice that could
fulfill that job that are are nationally
recognized assessments of of student
knowledge um but up to this point no
it's all based off of what the local
school district has developed for the
purpose of measuring the local school
district
competencies BR Miler you had a question
yeah Fred I think you should be
congratulated in attempting to go out
into the field and and get information
and it sounds to me in your testimony
this morning that you're intent is to
try to engage uh more individuals in the
next several days before the final draft
so I think as I look out to the audience
the committee here there's there's
anxiety around what that what that draft
the redraft is going to look like based
upon all the input that you have
received so um I think we should rate uh
resist any other comments around the the
current draft since it seems to be
irrelevant now based upon what you're
going to be doing so I I so thank you I
want a followup question uh with Rick's
dealing with competencies one of the
issues here with your Competency Based
education is that obviously there will
be opportunities for students to uh
receive that competency outside the
school uh the question that I guess I
really have is how do you make sure that
there's
quality in the same rigor that you would
have in school for a particular class
how do you ensure that that same quality
and rigor will take place in an
experience a learning experience for a
student in outside system uh what's your
what's your sense of how that's going to
take
place my sense is that um that that will
be done at the school level and um you
know I I I I wish I could say that that
you know just doing it the way we've
traditionally done it is good enough I
don't think it's good enough I mean I
you know I would like to think that if
we're really um if we're really uh
understanding at the local level what it
means um to have uh to be proficient or
have mastered the competencies that
somehow this student has to demonstrate
that that he or she knows this in in in
a way that they can use it in known and
unknown situations in the future and
they're not going to just forget it two
weeks later like it you know so many
including me you know did with tests
where he studied for the test passed the
test and a couple weeks later forgot you
know so much of it that to me is not
it's is not good enough so I'd like to
think that whatever we are doing um is
holding kids to higher standards if
we're if to me just a competency based
model alone is higher holding uh
students to higher standards so um you
know that uh how each School deals with
that I'm not sure what would what would
what would you add to to what you know
to that
question um looking at credits outside
of the classroom often times we look at
the ELO programs um and the specific
policies that districts have developed
around you know things either moving
through their ELO coordinators or
approved by the school principal um each
district sort of has their own set of of
policies for how they approve those ELO
opportunities and those outside the
classroom credit opportunities that the
District offers okay as a followup
please I think that's clear particular
with the ELO system that we have the
question I have is in the learn
everywhere program when you have an
experience there Dr Green what is the
oversight on the part of the Department
of Education in in those uh institutions
businesses whatever they might be to
ensure because there's that in that
situation School District isn't
necessarily involved in that learn
everywhere program what is the role that
the department plays in making sure that
there's rigor within the competencies
opportunity uh the learn ort program uh
exists outside of the 306s they have a
separate section it's the ed400 there is
a review process that the department
undertakes for any program that comes in
and applies to be a Lear ever program um
and then that review process and the
results of that go to the State Board um
but ultimately it's the State Board of
Education that approves learn everware
programs and the Department of Education
um tries to provide some review of those
those programs But ultimately goes to
the State Board of
Education further questions yes
representative
beler thank you Mr chair
um I think I would tend to agree with
the the sort of 20,000 foot view of
Competency Based idea I I have a little
bit of a concern when I'm trying to you
know meet rubber with Road and trying to
figure out the the details of how this
works so if uh if I could I think I have
two questions the first of which so
you've got traditional
classrooms um X number of students in
the class you have a you have a teacher
you may have other Professionals in the
classroom
uh curriculum is delivered everybody is
more or less on the same page and they
move along at the same time but moving
to a a competency based model where you
can't move on until you've achieved
either proficiency or Mastery at a
certain level suggests that every
student could potentially be at a
different place which necessitates a
personalized learning for each student
so rubber meeting Road this would seem
to either require a exponential increase
than the number of teachers or a heavy
Reliance on technology to deliver that
so is is that what we're looking at here
is leaning on technology things like
artificial intelligence and other
programs to help individualize learning
for
students it's it's a good question and I
so I'm going to speak not necessarily as
a a current Department representative
but as a former High School teacher that
had to implement Competency Based
systems in my chemistry and physics
classes um one of the ways in which I
did that was a little bit more old
school as opposed to newer Tech although
I actually as a science teeder love
technology and tried to integrate that
as much into my classroom um we actually
created a one wall of our classroom
essentially was a game board um and so
all the different squares across the
board were all the different
competencies that students had to move
through and with you know 25 or 26 kids
at any given point you might have a
group of five or six kids that are on
one competency a group of seven or eight
that are on another competency um and it
shifts the learning a little bit where
instead of and we had 90 minute blocks
we had an hour and a half so as opposed
to say you know lecturing for 45 minutes
and doing a lab activity um I would
maybe lecture for 25 or 30 minutes and
provide some additional homework where
kids would go home and they might watch
a video come in do a lab and as kids
would complete the you know whether it's
a a quiz or a test or a lab assignment
they' be able to move on to that next
competency was it harder absolutely um
was was it doable yes it just requires a
little bit more of Shifting when you're
providing some of that instruction being
able to wrap some of the instruction
into what kids brought home with them if
they could go home and watch a video on
you know the Discovery Education website
and come in they got a little bit of
that content as opposed to just relying
on me being the person to deliver that
direct instruction and that way in the
classroom I could work more directly
with groups of students as opposed to
just standing up in front of the whole
group now I would say that was my
experience as a a single individual
teacher trying to implement competence
based systems um I think there's a lot
of different ways of doing it much of it
does involve technology much of it
involves different groupings of students
so how are you grouping your kids within
your classroom and relying on kids
working together and supporting each
other almost through kind of like a peer
tutoring system within those
groups yes represent you have followup
yeah and and I'd like to answer it too
but but go ahead yes I just
uh thank you yes I just had one um one
followup uh which um is to the nature of
the competencies themselves I've looked
through a bunch of them and obviously
they're what you would expect for the
most part but I I wanted to ask are
there any or would you Advocate that
there would be any nonacademic
competencies involved in this such as
competencies based around social
competencies or emotional competencies
or things of that nature so that's
that's where you see um districts
creating those competencies for their
Community um you see this especially
with a lot of the school districts that
have adopted the portrait of a graduate
where they're looking at you know not
just the academic skills um but also
work skills social and emotional skills
what is it that they want to see for a
well-rounded student when they leave
high school and so many districts have
adopted specific competencies for their
schools and districts that go beyond
just say a math competency or an Ela
competency they get to some of those
softare skills or some of those work
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming um if I could follow up a little
bit on representative bel's question
taking this a little bit further if you
have a class that is in different points
um will you have a a year of class
freshmen or sophomores that are at
different points and some don't move on
to what we would consider regularly as
the next grade do you have people
straddling grades do we do you have the
classes 77 anymore or is it just
whenever you finished your proficiencies
you're
done we we tend to see it more um
influencing the numbers of students and
the groups of students that need
learning over the summer so
traditionally you know in non-competent
based systems you might have some
students that didn't quite get to the
point where they're ready they might
come in and do summer school now we're
seeing uh summer school be a little bit
more directed from a competency based
perspective where students have a set of
competencies that they didn't Master
during the school year they were just in
and they're working over the summer to
master those um sometimes with a
coordinator from the school sometimes um
with the specific teacher that they had
had the course with it really sort of
depends on the school and District
policies but we really see that being
directed more towards those summer
learning programs thank
you yes represent
luno thank you very much uh Rick Fred
and Nate so so uh I you know I I think I
think I'll I mean Rick really should
should speak for all of us but we
probably don't take ourselves too
seriously but we take the work very
seriously oh I take myself seriously oh
sure but I can still call you
RIT yes so but um but uh thanks very
much Mr chair and and U I wanted to sort
of swing back around to something you
talked about um a little bit earlier and
um and I think you were looking for for
feedback probably from the oversight um
uh committee on uh on things like
graduation requirements and so so uh
again going back to you know my time on
local school board uh we don't I I think
we don't in New Hampshire put a whole
lot of requirements on our students and
and uh I mean we do put some um I think
for graduation I just looked it up four
English three math two science a couple
of history and social studies and then a
half credit and a smattering of
different uh things but um but uh but uh
six um six credits in electives and
that's just you know the minimum 20 um
20 credit standard a lot of districts
have 22 24 26 credits and uh and
probably load up on a lot of uh
electives maybe some put world you know
uh World language in uh in there uh too
but um but uh you know as as I recall
student voice and choice is something
that's a real important component uh
particularly if you want to address what
what Fred what you wereing talking about
earlier keeping kids interested in
school and um and and a lot of times
voice voice and choice uh touch on these
things that that representative beler
was talking about outside of the normal
Academic Program um you know for example
a lot of kids show up to school because
they want to go to football practice and
they want to play in the game on
Saturday and and that's what gets them
to come into school and sit through math
class English class social studies class
everything else and and uh and uh and
they they they pick up some academics uh
and lunch along the uh uh along the way
but um but a couple of years ago I think
we saw you know an attack on on the um
what what what what I think is sort of
laid out as the the minimum program that
high schools have to offer which is
pretty well defined in
193e and um and and the um the the
justification for that was again back to
the Newport um question like if if
they're really not if they're struggling
in math and science and English in the
required uh elements then why require a
school to do any more than the than the
required um elements and um and my
concern is that takes away from voice
and choice for uh for the students to
fill out these electives whether that's
eight credit hour
you know or whatever eight credits in um
in unified arts in wood shop in framing
in in all these things that that that we
don't specify but but I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit on on the
connection um that the 306s uh could
have towards student voice and choice
gradu minimum graduation requirements
and then a a a program of studies that
that that really sort of provide
students with the voice and choice to be
able to graduate from high school with
with something that's meaningful and
important to them absolutely thank you
so much for asking representative
luno so um we um in working with uh as
representative Myer knows uh Tom rafo's
group uh the the uh New Hampshire
Coalition for business and education um
we um uh our organization kind of
brokered a an agreement um
between the Coalition and the school
administrators
Association on a new vision for high
school and that new vision for high
school
says that by 2025 obviously we're
creeping up on it now by 2025 virtually
every New Hampshire High School student
will earn or be on a personalized path
to earning a post-secondary or career
related
credential so when I mentioned earlier
about Senate Bill
276 it felt like you guys were having
the same
thought that
credentials of a Kid's Choice a
student's choice in um in a an area that
he or she would would want to pursue
should be available to virtually every
student in high school uh and and and
the school administrators have agreed
with that so how do we get to that place
but the so the choice is really and I
say this uh I've said this a million
times that the public schools need to
steal the word choice away from the
school choice folks so who say know you
can choose this school or choose that
school the way I phras it's like that's
20th century uh thinking on school
choice 21st century thinking on school
choice inside of a public system and you
can do you can have Limitless
opportunities available to you and they
can be inside a classroom they can be
online they can be in a real world
environment not possible if all we have
are traditional classroom opportunities
so when I say that I want kids waking up
in the morning they are so excited they
can't wait to get to school it's because
they're pursuing stuff that they want
for them not that the school wants for
them but that they want for them that
they see that this is something I can
use um to help me pursue my life path
whether it be college or career that
that we get that done in high school
with kids actually earning
credentials that are you know and I've
said a million times you tell me you
have a high school diploma I have no
idea what you know I have no idea what
you know you get a high school
diploma if you tell me you have a
welding license I kind of have an idea
of what you know you tell me you have an
associates degree and something I have
an idea of what you know you tell me
that you know you have some kind of a
credential this
institution um certifies that uh Joe
Smith has um has achieved the level of
such and such hanging on your wall frame
it can't take that away from me I can
take this out and get a real job that to
me is the direction that we need to
think about giving that opportunity for
our kids and I will tell you you know
when our kids start pursuing their
passion the things that they want
because we've done the right job
harnessing all of the assets of New
Hampshire the businesses nonprofits
talented individuals folks that have the
opportunity and the desire to provide
something exciting for our Public
Schools then we're going to be Someplace
Special you know I've often said you go
down the way to tell if we're there is
you go down on on Elm Street in
Manchester and and you grab anybody off
the street say how do we go about
educating our kids here um the way
they'd say now well we pick them up in
the bus in the morning we take them to
school 180 days blah blah blah okay when
that can change so that the average
person on the street can say the entire
community participates in the process of
Education our professional Educators
coordinate it all and it's driven
largely by our students with their
interest and dreams they are given the
opportunity to pursue their their own
paths that's when we'll know we have a
um a to me a real system a real
Competency Based system A system that is
going to serve our kids we're a fair way
from there to me that's the only way we
get there is if we all kind of go you
know and you know maybe you'd shape what
I just said differently that's fine
let's all get together and come to an
agreement on what that thing is going to
look like and then let's all pursue it
in a way that that's the kind of
education we're going to offer our kids
and to me that would be
exciting follow yes so so thanks Fred
but isn't that happening already in a
lot of places between between expansive
um uh program studies
El we are getting down the path that
that when when we first when I handed
this out to the team and I asked them
their thoughts um I asked how far down
the path do you think we are I mean you
know with this this 2005 2007 vision and
and the team answer was somewhere in the
20 to 25% of the way there not every
school some schools much farther down
the path others even be behind that
um but so excuse me
know I I you know I I I have been you
know you know called a dreamer many
times so and I accept it um but to me
excuse
doable it's only doable if if we're if
we're if we're having the kinds of
discussions like we're having here and
and and making decisions that are
ultimately going to put our kids in
those kinds of positions so that they
can we can create that that great system
that that is built for the 21st century
not designed off of this old model that
really doesn't work for a huge hunk of
kids you know it it uh uh the you know
the uh uh I you know I was lucky I I
found a uh I had a passion I had two
passions kids and rock and roll those
were my two passions and I pursued both
of them and they were and it it provided
me with a a very very rewarding life not
every kid who finishes at the bottom of
his or her class like uh like I did
comes out in a good spot you know a lot
of them it it uh the the thought that
they're not bright it it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy and they have
they have uh they don't um they just
don't think that they're special and so
and and and maybe don't pursue the kinds
of things that they might have if they
if they only were put in a position to
um to be a star in whatever it was that
they wanted to become a star in I became
a star in the rock and roll business in
you know musical instruments and um but
it was it was a something I was
passionate about and uh you know and it
worked for me and you know and it it
changed my own vision of myself because
I thought I was Dumb and um and after a
while I started thinking maybe I'm not
as dumb as I thought and we've got to
make sure that we have a system that is
not designed and and and to me this this
is the system we have it is designed for
kids for kids like my wife who who want
to sit in the classroom listen to the
teacher make you know take great notes
get an A on the test get the gold star
in her forehead that's what she did and
she loved it she's still a teacher and a
great one um the you know but for kids
like me that didn't work and so how do
we have a system that works for every
kid and that's that's what you know
that's what I am hoping that together we
can all agree on what this looks like um
on what you know what the shape of this
um looks like uh and you know and I
believe this is doable I absolutely
believe this is doable but it's going to
take it's going to take leadership it's
going to take a concerted effort and a
belief on everybody's part that we can
pull this off okay I I have a question
then then Katie I'll get to you um I'm
still little bit concerned about what
who establishes the proficient level I'm
a I'm a US history teacher let's say
and there is no Statewide assessment in
those areas we have it in Reading Lang
language arts writing science
mathematics that's it so so I am going
to have to develop that District level
competency or or am I not uh uh where
where do I find the state competency the
proficient level of Competency for US
history or do I write my own
competencies and every teacher here is
going to write something different so
and then you have schools that are
accredited here with the New England
neie and you have another one over from
the northwest Association schools and
colleges they're coming in accredited is
that the standard we're reverting to is
that of an accrediting institution or
some kind of Competency set Prof at a
professional level by the
state so um thank you U so much of that
is done as part of the curriculum work
that curriculum teams do in schools and
districts um often times it's done with
a a team of teachers either working
within a subject or within a subject and
across grade bands so uh in my example
uh when I was a teacher we would get
together every year as a science
department and we would look at all of
the science competencies that we had
developed for all the different science
courses and this is one of the reasons
why so much of that is done at a local
level because you need sets of
competencies for every course that you
have and oftentimes districts have a
wide variety of courses but we also
leaned heavily on the work that we knew
was happening in the districts around us
um and we leaned heavily on the work
that we knew was being done at the
middle school because we had to have an
understanding of what the Middle School
teachers were teaching and what the
Middle School teachers were considering
proficient so that we understood the
level at which the students were coming
to us in high school oftentimes our
professional development days would
include some days where the high school
team and the middle school team would
meet together to look at those
curricular progressions across you know
fifth grade through 12th grade to make
sure that students were were building
along a path of proficiency that made
sense so that those students were
prepared each year um but so much of
that work is the work of building a
curriculum and building competencies
that's that's done at a local level um
some districts have curriculum directors
or curriculum administrators that help
to lead that work within the district
but it it's really done on a you know a
course specific basis because every
course has to have a set of competencies
attached to that and then I would say
too it's it's a little bit less about
you know grading whether a student got a
70% or an 80% or 90% um but you know if
you have you know chemistry course there
going to be 10 or 12 competencies
associated with that course and within
the curriculum you're going to have a
set of very specific assignments for
each of those competencies that a
student has to complete those
assignments with a level of proficiency
to be considered proficient on that
particular competency and it could
include a collection of uh laboratory
ports uh student writing uh quiz or unit
test but it's usually not just one thing
that determines a student set of
proficiency but students's performance
across a variety of different types of
Assessments that then leads to the
teacher saying yes on this particular
competency that student is proficient um
and that really is done at the teacher
level so it's a local issue yeah
curriculum and instruction very much is
driven by local teachers yeah yeah Katie
representative petno yes it's
representative Pell chairman lad thank
you you're welcome thank you for being
here and thank you for taking my
question um Mr veronte you've mentioned
school choice several times um and I'm
wondering and and you also mentioned
meeting every child's needs and meeting
their interests and passions would do
you recommend doing this within their
assigned school districts or would or
would you be open to the concept of
opening the borders of the districts for
open enrollment across the districts in
order to meet these students
needs uh personally uh I am a anytime
any place anyhow any Pace kind of person
uh so um I have uh I have uh no problem
doing whatever is in the best interest
of the student um I the the simple
example that I used to give can't give
it anymore um be um because of a recent
change but I I I used to say what if we
have I live in Durham so what if we have
in our district this this um 63 240 lb
kid that you know runs
the99 and um
and uh but we don't have a football team
at Oyster River um shouldn't you know I
mean this is the possibility of of of
giving this kid an opportunity to get a
college scholarship or what else
shouldn't that that student be able to
go to a school where he or she can um
you know can get that kind of
opportunity I I I found out recently o
River has joined with Portsmouth so now
that so now the kids can play on the on
the Portsmouth team so you know so I
like those kinds of choices so you know
to me I've always said that if we're
trying to get this Vision done inside
the walls of our schools it'll never
happen that we need our community we
need the entire Community to make this
happen and some of my Republican friends
don't like me saying this but Hillary
Clinton was right when she said it takes
a village it's like it really requires
all of us to be in this the community
needs to say we're part of the process
of educating our kids and um and to and
and to me uh that's if we do that well
then um then the sky the limit for the
possibilities that can offer our our
students so you know so I hope I
answered the
question uh represent Woodcock thank you
chairman L good afternoon gentlemen
thank you so much for being here
um I I I appreciate your passion I I
thought it was back in uh grad school
with education philosophy 101 it was
it's all the things we can dream I I
believe that and I believe in the
particularly the evaluation of CTE and
how those skills are very clearly
defined you can tell you put the SAR in
one way or the other it doesn't work we
got that um however a couple of things I
I were asked I was confused about
uh representative whatever the name is p
my right asked a couple times about the
finances and you sort of just let that
go representative chair asked about the
competencies in place now and I I think
um they were supposed to be put in place
by starting 2004 in in every school now
that's correct to be there some comp is
when the regul went in place the the the
I'm sorry the uh minimum standards
actually said that this must be in place
by the 2009 2010 school year right so it
supposed to be in place a decade ago and
representative lad's question was if I
understood it was he was asking you if
doe had everything done anything about
checking on that making sure all the
schools did that and you the respon the
response was basically no um we we they
hadn't done that but understand not no
but not good enough is my in my opinion
okay then there is a mechanism that de
yes going down to schools and checked on
besid just sleep check off okay good so
I will get to my question by the way
that that 240 pound 100 99 Dash somebody
would find him he would get an education
he would he would be he would be found
we get where we live but my question is
this I agree with you um we used to call
it performance evaluation then we call
it authentic assessment now we call it
compens it's all the same thing show us
what you can do and how you can be I got
all that but is I don't know if any
school system where they have teachers
in there saying I don't want you to show
me how you can do it but we show it this
way but what we have is school system
that are desparate and they're desperate
because their funny base and their
opportunity for youngsters comes on
their funny base so I was thinking back
because I don't know Chinese education
but I do had your quote that said more
kids in AP schools in China than they
are in New Hampshire at all I wrote that
down and I said I wonder who funds the
schools in China I wonder about that I
wonder if was the property taxes funded
the schools in China I don't know do you
know that I heard your qu you quote I
think the government does oh okay so
that's that's just so it goes back to my
point my my point is this that the
regardless of it's authentic or
performance or companies and I like that
I was in systems I had a chance to work
in those types of systems and I believe
in that and I believe that every
youngster has the right to get that go
but then I think there has to be
some strong creative step or uh Movement
by this committee Beyond just saying
we're going to go to comery base and
every school is going to do it and this
is what you going do it still leaves the
void in how are you going to fund it and
if you continue to leave that void am I
talking Li can't hear well if you
continue to leave that void that says
you're going depend on taxpayers yeah
it's wood you get it uh taxpayers then
is not going to work because there's no
school system with teachers that I know
say we don't want it to work now they're
trying to make it work they don't have
the resources so is your committee going
to have some supplement that's going to
say you know what folks if you really
want to change the system and you want
to make it eligible for everyone to
change the system you have to give
everyone the same opportunity and that's
resources so I is your Comm stepping
forward to say that as well or or am I
just mistaken um well you're mistaken
but I love what you're saying and in in
the sense that that I mean I have been
fighting the education funding fight
since
1992 and um and I have a plaque on my
wall um uh that myself and two others uh
in 1995 one the Josiah Bartlet better
government uh award for our plan for a
flat tax on property to fund an adequate
education in New Hampshire's Public
Schools it was the introduction of the
modern day concept of the State Property
Tax the state property tax in my opinion
which has nothing to do with this
committee and I wish it would but it I
mean because I'd love the responsibility
of working with folks on on education
funding but education I've I've argued I
got the opportunity to argue before the
New Hampshire Supreme Court on this
issue so I know the issue very well I
don't disagree with you um but that has
nothing to do not nothing to do it has
certainly has something to do with how
uh you know how well our schools are are
are uh are funded and and uh but but our
our committee can't can't address that
by that uh so it's not part of our
charge I wish it was it's not part of
our charge and um you know so I and and
even when this committee is done I will
personally continue uh
pursuing um the the whole notion of
doing education funding
right real quick you're into my lunch
hour oh you're light either that's
okay T one brief question yeah that that
being said um sir I understand your
passion for funding as most people here
uh have the same passion but that
doesn't get to the question and the
question is if and I understand your
background for the first 20 minutes with
your background and I appreciate that so
I know where you're coming from that
being said however is this committee
going to be bold enough in their
introduction of their passion to the to
the uh state board and to the D over
here is the next level to say that all
this is great if it is funded I mean you
I understand not you charge but that is
part of the the basket that's the
wrapping on the basket you can't get to
the basket without all the rapping so my
question is are is is your commune going
to say if this is could but can't work
on the funding system we have
now uh it it is well can it work on the
now yeah I I I believe it can work with
the funding system that we have now is
it going to work well with the funding
system we have now uh I have a problem
with the funding system that we have now
personally but we're on another subject
it's like it's like you know you're
asking me to put a different hat on I
get the Hat ask stand up when you make
presentation to the state and say this
will work if we fund it that's all I'm
asking representative we're really off
topic here and we're you know I'm going
to allow one more question represent
Damon you haven't had anything to say
here but we have to take a break here
because we have another one starting up
at one o'clock in this room represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I've actually
had a lot to say in my head um however I
think it's really important that the
word Equity be articulated in this room
now and a recognition that the draft of
the standards that we currently have
available to look
at completely erods any attention to
equity for students and uh educating
professionals and I would hope that the
revised draft would be much more like
what we are currently operating under
and that Equity would be clearly stated
as a need for schools to address thank
you thank you very much uh Nate and Fred
for can I can I just have Nate address
that for just one second representative
for sure was there a question in
there kind of a question and I'd like
I'd love for Nate to respond I know
you'd like to respond you have a he
respon I don't know if it's
interrogative sense a question or what
okay go ahead sure so there was an
earlier draft where there's a section in
the 306s that talked about schools being
required to identify um gaps that are
found in equity and one of the original
drafts that changed that to requiring
schools to have a plan for addressing
underachievement of students what we've
done now is we've actually combined
those two statements together so that
schools are both required to identify
gaps in equity the original language of
the 36 as well as develop a plan for how
the school intends to address those gaps
in
equity better than what it
was I appreciate the answer but that
doesn't sound adequate okay we're going
to cut it off right just a point of
claric
when you have the new
draft rent cordelan and I were just kind
of kits in here a little bit will there
be a side by side with the new draft of
the new language versus the old language
I will talk to our rules folks and see
what we can put together thank you I
don't know how long it took you to do
that Jen but this 109 or what 20 pages
is one heck of a task but I want to
thank you very much Fred and both Fred
and Nate and all those that came that
have been part of of this process uh we
look forward to
receiving the next update or
draft and as with any process there's
got to be some accountability to ensure
we do a lot of statutory changes here on
this committee and it doesn't get done
out in the field and there's no Hammer
that Doe has to ensure it gets done so
I'm hoping we can because this is a
direction we got to go
in but there's a lot of local control
here that's going to be making those
decisions and uh somehow we got to find
that sweet spot as you said
earlier yes uh thanks very much uh Rick
and and um and thanks again for being
here but could we also get from the
Department the order of operations um uh
for this just to make sure we understand
where this committee and where the
oversight Commission fits into the um
the um um yeah that's part of the
process which we'd like to have we spoke
of at the very beginning yes right
terrific thank you okay thank you very
much for coming we're going to thank you
so
much thank you very
for
the uh Committee of the hold to address
afternoon the first bill which I'd like
to take up today would be HB
352 this is relative to excused absences
due to a student's mental or Behavioral
Health we we had a pretty good
met
and several of the things which we
identified without looking at my notes
right here is that many of the loow the
school districts currently have policies
in place dealing with
absence they also require that fear out
for any kind of an absent that a
communication be made with the school by
the adult
at
home and if not they'll call
you and thirdly we also know that if
you're out for a medical reason Beyond
five days that you have to come in with
a
doctor's uh note indicating just what
kind of a condition you
had and so I'm also
concerned that
there's room for abuse with this with
this
legislation that an
individual like myself would like to
stay up and watch a football game being
held between Cal State and Montana or
something such as that on the west coast
with a different start time and I'm up
all night so I'm going to take a mental
health the next day to stay
home um that doesn't slice it right
so I think there's room for abuse and I
think when you are absent
from with a doctor's certificate yes
there's an opportunity perhaps we can
have some support given you if you need
a special plan 50 what 5014
504 which is necessary we also want to
make sure that um when you are absent
you something occurs so that we know
nothing's happened on the way to school
but lastly the the school has to know
where you are at all times they
should um and the last point I was going
to think of
was
the just dropped there's a lot of
reasons why I just can't support this
bill any follow-up discussion on
it are we all on the same
no
I rick one question I guess not not
withstanding uh the abuse that you talk
about not withstanding the abuse that
Rick talked about my concern would be is
that if a
student is in
fact under the care of a
physician and has acknowledged with the
school that there this is not an
incident kind of a thing this would be
either a chronic or um or somebody's
under the care and has to be out of
school I mean that I would think that
I'd want some
protection for that not the abuse of
issue but I do believe that there are
some
students uh who
may be under care and um that there
ought to be some allowances now whether
or not that can already be done in the
school district and this is this uh
piece of legislation is not relevant or
needed that's a whole another question
but um I don't know I that would be that
would be my concern now do you believe
that if I'm going to take a mental
health day for whatever the reason might
be because I'm allowed how many of them
five and I get credit for attendance at
school for that given day well I know
there's a huge test coming up tomorrow
I'm just not going to go to school I'm
taking a mental health
attendance so you're asking me that
question well I'm asking the whole
committee is that you know is that right
so Rick
yeah yeah you know what one of the one
of the pieces of information we received
during the hearing on 352 was that other
states looks like at least 12 other
states have adopted similar measures and
so you know we should be able to get an
to to the question that you just asked
um Mel you know with respect to what
happens to a student if they um if they
you know take a mental health excused
absence on a day of a test and we
probably be able to find out from those
other states what um what they've seen
as far as um as far as you know I don't
know what you want to call it unintended
consequences uh as a result of students
taking those um mental health days um
you know I don't think I don't think New
Hampshire is necessarily being the
area yes represent Hall yes thank you um
I'm thinking the whether it's mental
health whether it's a flu whether it's
whatever the parent writes a note that
says my child was out sick period if you
get a doctor's note the doctor's not
going to tell you what they have I don't
think they shouldn't they should just
say you know they cannot attend school
for the next two weeks they shouldn't
tell them why shouldn't tell them
because of mental health or because they
got diabetes or whatever it is
so I I think what we have in place right
now
works go ahead it's it's it's just a
subcommittee or
basically okay thanks um I did my
homework I called some of the schools in
my district and said what happens when a
parent says a child's not coming
and sometimes it's the secretary that
takes it sometimes it's the nurse that
ask the questions but they said we have
to ask them uh if they have uh the
symptoms because we have to still track
flu and coid cases and I said well if
somebody wanted a mental health day
could they get around that by just
saying doesn't have a fever doesn't have
flu or coid but is is too sick to come
to school and they said that would work
that'd be fine I said what if you had
special category for mental health days
that would be a lot of extra paperwork
and it would fall on the secretary or
the nurse who didn't really neither
which really wanted that um and then
they asked uh I said um what happens you
know if they mount up and he said well
they would just be counted the same way
the other ones are if they're three SE
once you get to three days or three
illnesses in that term then you get
kicked to a different level and you get
some intervention so they they've got
their eyes on it all the time there is a
way around it with saying
that you don't have to to admit to a
mental health day but if somebody needs
it and they need an excused absence
there's a way to do it without this I
think I think it's suurus what they're
asking for
here who's next represent
Woodcock thank you formal informal thank
you chairman lad
um my my concerns are twofold uh Rick on
the the piece uh as they were before we
first discussed it when I was here back
in February
um the part that you're talking about
about being considered for tenant which
is number four in that this uh ELR it's
only calculating the average daily
attendance it has nothing to do with the
youngster being there it's for the
school but more than that I go back to
item three um which says the youngsters
shall not have their grades adversely
affected by the lack of class attendant
and I know the school districts
including where I have uh been in the
State uh in two different school
districts in New Hampshire that if the
youngster is out x amount of days it
impacts their academic grade or the
ability to make up work so uh if a
parent if they youngsters is having a
behavioral issue and and I I don't call
it in uh then you start to accumulate
that data but if I have the opportunity
to call like my Johnny's having a
problem today Behavior D um then they
make the not of that so he has an
opportunity or she has an opportunity
the time comes and the mentally
competent feel better to make up the
work um so it's it's not like just the
youngster saying I'm not going to go
today CU I have a test tomorrow they can
do that now uh and they whatever the
school policy to make up a test they
will I mean you're not going to get out
of the test but we're talking about
someone doesn't become mentally ill or
have a behavioral issue just the day of
the test unless they Haven to have bu be
for exams and we're talking about a real
problem and that's a concern I have Rick
with three and four um four doesn't
impact anything the average daily tenant
but three three impacts to me my concern
is the youngster uh can be Nega impact
but something he have no control of and
that's that's a poor I I would suggest
that that's a poor School District
policy but that's the policy most folks
have because we don't have this uh
caveat to it thank you yeah further
discussion reent
cordelli thank you the current
statute uh requires that school boards
uh except uh establish policies related
to all this um including a definition of
excused absence and a process for
considering exceptions to absences not
excused um process for Intervention when
necessary with individual students um so
I I think it's pretty well covered in
that um it requires these policies to be
in place
already they don't go ahead they don't
require that these two conditions be
included in the Poli
it's like it's like setting the
standards for curricula they don't tell
you what they have to be in place this
this says you know what this has to be
in the policy that's all it says doesn't
tell you how the school's going to deal
with it just says this has to be
considered the policy that's all and
we're not this is not 20 I mean I'm I'm
sure the the issues 20 years ago are
similar but they seem to have been
exacerbated over the last five or six
years we have a lot more youngsters who
are dealing with significantly more
emotional and behavioral issues so I I
just think now it's it's it's it just
tells the school board folks wake up you
have to include these two that's all
this says thank you so what's your
definition of mental health I have a
mental health issue I'm just going to
say I didn't come to school today I have
mental health issue what could that be
or you are you speaking as you or as a
parent I mean you you the youngster you
a parent either let's say you're the
parent of that student okay are you
parent of that student calls in you got
you got to believe it what's your option
you have a question on it I mean if the
if they're legitimate they have enough
high enough time saying those words to
you to a secretary or a nurse or anyone
else or teach you Tak tenant it's not
legitimate not a damn thing you do about
it on any absence so if the parent calls
in and say my child's not well that's it
that's it yeah why do you have to have a
policy then for mental health if they
can adding you're adding these two
pieces in there because school districts
some don't have that and you have the
attendance caveat that says you miss x
amount of days it STS a negative impact
grade that's all representative
beler thank you Mr chair and just to
follow up on some of that the way that I
see this particular policy being written
is first of all right away I don't think
any of us dispute the fact that
sometimes a mental health day might be
necessary for a student
um however currently I don't see
anything first of all in law that would
prevent them from taking a mental health
day they can do that um second what this
seems to do by by calling out mental
health specific speically as opposed to
physical health it seems to be setting
up a discriminatory system where
somebody with mental health is going to
be treated differently than somebody
with a physical element where somebody
who might need to be out sick for an
extended time because of long Co or
whatever is going to be treated
differently from somebody with a mental
health issue they would be failed
because they missed more than five days
whereas somebody with a mental health
issue would not be and that seems like a
problem if this if this is necessary to
be addressed it seems like this needs to
be broadened in scope to include um
physical elements not just mental and
then we could have to debate on
that
yeah I hate I hate to do this but could
we uh ask our retired
superintendent on the committee on
this oh did have to deal with it number
one
um I think we had a discussion about
this already once and I was not in
support of this bill because I think
there are mechanisms in place to excuse
families that are struggling with a
student in with a mental health crisis
and or a behavioral crisis and nine
times out of
10 the school administration School
nurse whatever has worked with a parent
and knows that there's a diagnosed
mental health
issue if you've got a student that say
has behavioral issues because they've
experienced posttraumatic stress
disorder someone in that school will
hopefully know that because if that
child goes beyond the 5 days of absence
hopefully there is a 504 plan to make
accommodations for that or if it's so
severe that they have to miss a lot that
there's an IEP with an identification of
other health
impaired so there I think there are
mechanisms in place to make sure that
those kids and that parent that calls
and says okay today's a day that they
have to be out the school will also
already
know that it's part of their mental
one so we're not going to we can't you
know we don't we're not all here right
now and but we can take a straw vote we
could take a
vote but um how many people at this
point in time saying this bill is
already taken care of through policy and
procedures in the school so it's not
needed how many people are on that page
so who's counting
three s eight 10 11 you got 12 I got 11
now so I think we have a majority there
saying that I don't think anybody's
saying
that we we don't want to deal with the
issue mental health but I think at this
point in time we have a process we're
going to do
is complicate that process and and I've
had that happen in the schools I've had
in fact I had a nurse back up north name
was Mary Bell and Mary was on top of
everything that was going on with the
families especially those families were
maybe going through a divorce or there
had been some kind of abuse in the
family and we
understood and and so I think that
there's that awareness but I also
believe that
there's ways that a parent could call in
and say my child isn't well today that's
it now if that happens five consecutive
days then we start asking what's going
on get a doctor's note saying what the
medical issue
is so um
I I'm good with uh you know moving on
Beyond this bill and and uh we're going
to have a lot of bills like that this
year and we're going to have to start
deciding now is it already occurring
through policy in the schools if it is
let's move
on yes represent cascaden um just want
to add that it's really critical for the
parent to have a relationship with the
school because see the school is
resourceful and if the parent isn't
needs resources the school should be
able to
offer what resources they have or where
the parent can find resources yeah so
there has to be that communication
between the two
because you want to support kids in all
their
capacities
okay Al righty so let's go on to the
next bill then so with that we'll
probably have a motion come forward
during the November 13th meeting to itl
that bill and we'll write the blur in
why okay the next bill we have two other
it
yeah we have one that's modifying
e well I'm trying to find my sheet I
yes and it and it does have bipar it's
it's if you look at
it the majority people signing on were
senators and then there's four
reps which represented Cornell was one
um so and there was bip Parson part and
senators
I'll just lead off with what
my concern would
be
that we have academic standards and we
presented them in the last time the
packets are from
2003 where there's health education
taught at elementary middle and high
schools within each of those levels
there's a component for mental
health so that means these have been
approved by the State Board of
Education we also had the question asked
today of the 306 people are you taking
out the elements within
30640 Health he said no that's remaining
in that keeps mental health then in the
rule making process which is an approved
by Jael car which is the joint
legislative committee administrative
rules so it is a part of our curriculum
it is a part of the rule making already
do we need it as
a and it is a subtopic of Health where
health and wellness are already in the
adequacy part of
193e are we going to start adding in all
the other components of Health
inadequacy nutrition
physiology substance abuse
alcoholism underneath adequacy or is
just the topic health and
wellness Incorporated according to the
state board it
does so I see it's not
needed in this section of
adequacy I'm talking about 151 which is
bill so you're you're concerned that
they
they luminating specific topics that
would be already covered by the topic
health or perhaps covering the General
Public Health by local ccul not perhaps
the curriculum guidelines specify it
shall be taught oh hell not these
subject me mental health is within the
framework I think uh represent cascaden
just waved it to you
yeah yeah
yeah so all of
the
um examples that you just cited
nutrition physiology substance abuse
Etc all fall either Under the Umbrella
of physical health or mental health so I
don't think that the possibility of
putting mental health as a curriculum
requirement opens a door to
listing you know a myriad of other
conditions because there's really two
categories of Health there's physical
health and mental health and everything
falls under one of those if we only say
health conventionally the word health is
understood to mean physical health it's
not routinely
utilized as the broad umbrella of all
Health including mental health I wish it
were but it's not and so look at 306 I
specify mental health it specifies it in
30640 but that's different from putting
it in statute these have been approved
legislature and I guess I'm not as
confident as you are that the answer
this morning is the outcome that we will
have in those revie
ISS and I think it's critically
important that students
learn the
basics of mental health risk factors
protective factors common concerns then
my response to that would be and I think
I mentioned at the last meeting if in
30640 I wouldn't put mental health here
underneath adequacy I'd stick it in
where we've stuck in other issues
dealing with health under studies which
bill clarify what you mean by the next
bill Oh you mean the we have three bills
the 505 one the other mental health Bill
we have not yet discussed sorry where we
put in physical education we put in HIV
we put in all the other topics which
come underneath health I put it there
rather than adding in another area under
adequacy
which is you
know it's already there underneath the
topic
Health if we're going to put social
studies down there our history down
there are we going to start then putting
down the Civil War the Depression era
what happened in the 70s and 60s civil
rights or are that is that already there
underneath the curriculum Frameworks I
think we' got to be very careful how far
we go with putting things into
adequacy
so thank you Mr chair so you know we we
actually took up um similar discussions
in the Commerce Committee when it came
to health insurance U and uh and mental
health parity and and uh and as as um
hope was saying typically you know
health is is is is read and understood
to mean physical health and so it was
very important in a lot of the insurance
RS to spell out mental health as being
as being part of what is meant by Health
um and and I I agree I mean I think the
the department has um has over the years
done a done a good job to make sure that
uh that it included mental health in the
definition of Health but if that's not
required Then That Could That Could
disappear um and um so so I I mean I I
hear what you're saying on on this this
I I think maybe it's it's um it's not
needed based on what the Department's
done so far but it doesn't mean that the
department will continue to do that um
in the future and uh um uh on the o on
the other hand though Mr chair maybe the
definition of of Health particularly as
it relates to our insurance laws not as
it includes mental health maybe we can
lean on that um as saying look the
modern definition of Health includes
mental health and maybe you're right
maybe maybe this isn't necessary um now
that we're in 2023 if you look at
18910 where it says studies Roman 2 it
says the school board shall ensure that
health
education physical education to include
the importance of exercise and wellness
are taught to pupils as part of the
curriculum specifically to include
physiology hygiene health health and
interpersonal relationships physical
education and wellness as they relate to
the effects of school Alcohol and Other
Drugs prevention of sexual violence
child abuses there's a whole Litany of
areas there we're talking about it's
easy to immerse if we have to mental
health right into that area under
studies so it will say that the local
Schoolboard shall ensure that that is
taught
um isn't that what the next
that's what the next the next
Comprehensive Health I I don't like the
word comprehensive at all but I have no
objections to mental health being
inserted but not underneath
um adequacy
1938 for a lot of reasons yeah fair
enough and I think I think you're right
under studies it certainly um uh if it
were if it were put there it would uh it
would make it clear that that mental
Health Rick I think
also as you queried this
morning we don't know what's going to be
in the standards that's right so my
sense is why don't we wait and see
exactly what well that's I was hoping to
get after yeah sure yeah yeah yeah it's
coming out we
yeah they said they were going to take
these to the State Board in what
November November 9 9th meet we meet the
13th yeah it's really tight yeah if they
meet when they say they're going to meet
right
yeah but I agree I want to know for sure
whether it's going to be in rules or not
if it's in rules I feel very comfortable
where we are because we also have it in
the curriculum framework
yeah
y but if we're going to do something I'd
rather do something and put it where it
belongs just like we did with personal
finance literacy we also said that that
could be embedded into a course so it's
um
this Mr chair
yes so I appreciate your explanation and
the contrast between adequacy putting it
into adequacy versus
studies so if 505 which places mental
health in
studies were ought to pass I would be
comfortable with um a no on
151 you're doing that on premise that
may we modify Roman 2 and
18910 and say the something the health
education to include mental health
physical education you know I said you
know we can work it in there somehow yes
and put it in the proper location this
is where Anthony was advising us to put
a lot of this stuff if it's not in rule
if it's not a framework where you have
an academic standard do not add any more
stuff into the adequacy part of the law
here and is now gone to California
calculus is that a strategy that we
could play
with
here so I think if we're going to have
that strategy then the only thing I
would change in the latter Bill the one
we haven't I'd take the word
comprehensive
out and just the words that they'll help
help and insert that in studies not
where's that now Glen in what chapter
law it's in 18910 yeah two moment two
yeah so it's in the right
place yeah represent cascaden um yeah
definitely I agree my my problem with
that 504 was the word comprehensive
because what does it mean so if that
word came out of this this bill does
that mean that the
current framework curriculum would still
work yeah yeah okay even if it's 20
years old great I know it needs to be
Rewritten but I mean schools have had to
focus a lot more on Mental Health these
last 5 10 years okay even more so
now so I guess if we're good with this
strategy we've done our
homework so we need to bring forward an
amendment to just take out the word
comprehensive
yeah and we're we're also going to
determine what the state board is doing
on the 9th was it on the
9th hopefully they keep mental health in
306 and all the other components of
they but I also heard conflicting
comments from some people participating
that are meeting tomorrow with them that
there's one area where this person
saying all the elements in science have
been
stripped however that's not what I was
told by Dr Green or by Fred they're
saying it's going to be in so it's I
think it's
more a rumor right so Rick along those
task force issues yeah that's not our
problem so so along those lines do we
want to um um what what do you think
about scheduling a um
oversight committee
meeting for after the board receives the
um rules yeah I think we'll have to do
that we should do that though when we
can get a copy of what they're
presenting whether they're sending a
package with the draft as we've seen it
and then all the hearing stuff setting
aside that's not what I want to see I
want to see this
merged or at least acted upon if want it
fine if they don't they don't but I'd
like to see that final report going to
the
board and for us to
schedule then a oversight committee but
we're going to have to do it quickly
because that November is coming on as
fast right right well the the 10th would
be the first date that yeah could even
be possible to do that we should know
probably the week before whether it's on
the agenda for theard right but but you
also I mean the report goes to the board
we'll have what that final report is but
the board may also make some changes in
so given what representative Miler just
said and the timelines for the
legislative retain
bills I would vigorously support an OTP
on 505 without the word
comprehensive regardless of what happens
this fall with the 306 because we're not
going to know the final outcome of that
before we need to vote on this we can
have an amendment made doing what you
saying but we're not going to act on
that till the
13th when we should know a little bit
more if we don't know we can go ahead
and move that
Amendment we'll know more but we won't
it won't be final well it could still
get
modified
well
I don't know well we be in any event
we'd be ready for the 13th and we're
just 1 the 13th if we don't know we
could move forward with it that's
all um but we should know we should
know because we have to have our reports
out that week of the 13th and 13th is a
Monday so they're meeting on the 9th
which is Thursday
there any further comments about that
because it's not even 2 o'clock we can
get home by
3:30
so so Rick Rick with with with respect
to rules which all of this seems to be
you know related to uh to the 306s um
does
it are are the rules I mean the rules
have to come to the over s it committee
for recommend review and recommendation
do they also have to go to the
legislative to the legisl to the general
court for approval prior to going to JL
car that's something that you read it
this morning or somebody read that was
it's it's it's it's very poorly written
law it is very poorly that's right but
it looks to me that that that the
statute does not call out JL car and 541
rulemaking for that but that it has to
go to the general court for approve any
modifications to the minimum standards
after this the date of the you know 193
court that's why I introduced an LSR
which is both saying that the academic
standards and the minimum standards for
public school approval must go by uh the
oversight committee yeah and and then
and then
e2a Roman 4A says changes made by the
Board of Education to the school
approval standards through Ru making
after the effective date of the section
so law shall not be included within the
standards that constitute the
opportunity to deliver an adequate
Education Without prior adoption by the
general
court the standards for an adequate
education which is part of it is that
the minimum standards for public school
approval it says changes made by the
to the school approval standards through
Ru making yeah keep after the effective
date of this section yeah shall not be
included within the standards that
constitute the opportunity for the
delivery of an adequate Education
Without prior adoption by the general
court that's kind of
confuted blah blah blah yeah but but but
it also May May mean that that when the
when the legislature adopted 193 e2a
that they were taking its role in terms
of delivering a constitutionally
adequate education very
seriously well well my concern was based
upon Dr Green's comment this morning
when he said H their attorneys are
looking at this yeah the qu the question
I would have is should we get the AG's
office for example involved in just
giving us an advisory opinion on their
what they they view this particular
rather than waiting for the Department
is as chair we we do have legal advice
to this committee okay which we can get
from Jim C upstairs house council is
where we ought to go let's let's seek
that out let's get their opinion on we
don't we don't know we don't know what
the Department's going to say but we
need at least from from the house
standpoint we know what the Department's
going to say
well we can do it yeah that's what I say
yeah but it's better to get it clear now
rather than having to have that fight
later well they you know although I
think this might be more than a house
counsel question this is a um a question
of law not a question of what the house
can do or not do and and I it probably
resides at the department question is
that they have the authority the state
board has authority to adopt the
standard of public school approval
that's in law separate section yep right
right at the to now to do that does the
process involve approval from
us from the legislative
oversight and then from the general
court Hope Has a you see hope has a
question but if it was the General Court
approving it it becomes law right and
there's no need for them to be adopted
by the state board what it says so
you ni to have a ruling
yeah from home I think it's
doj I would start with House Council I
think we got start with with our own
Council which I can get a you know
something back there very quickly within
hours KCK up well if it does it does but
at least we have gone our route the
people are working and assigned to
directly work with us I I I think Rick
is correct I think uh the house needs to
have a position on what this is all
right if the department then comes up
with an alternative that's when you go
to the doj to try to get some clarity on
that but I I think you're correct direct
start with the how house councel get a
clarification then we'll see where it
goes from there I think you're right
yeah I think right as well to do it to
preempt it not after the know before
there our
house
represent Cas um just something I want
others to kind of put their antennas out
too because my perception on the first
draft that I've gone through on the
minimum standards is that the word
School approval has been removed
multiple times and it makes me a little
nervous to think are we doing minimum
standards to align to the adequacy so
that the language is the same in
both or are we maintaining minimum
standard for public school approval or
School
approval and that made me a little
nervous if we dropped a school approval
process so just I don't know if it's
just my perception going through those
drafts but I wanted to voice it so
people would kind of say no I mean it's
very important that all schools have a
minimum standard to follow I mean like
Fred said this morning you know how do
we know what they've had well if they're
all approved schools you know what
they've had they've all mastered well
proficient whatever you want to use
they've all followed the minimum
standards for school approval and I'm
afraid of that school approval process
being dropped but that's just
my feeling and I wanted other people I
I'm on the same page you are seriously
yes but I but I have a I have a
concern that the have you ever seen a
report rep as superintendent you should
have on the visitation that comes to
your
District to assess your performance in
terms of the minimum standards for
public school approval I've seen several
of them several years back a one-page
handwritten
job which
conveys not a whole
lot and that's my concern that we've
been talking about competencies and all
that but when they go out they don't
have the staff to do this properly and
it's partially our problem as a
legislature we have not funded the
Department of Education with a
curriculum and the other Personnel
necessary to comply with it's like Steve
applebe sent out the request for
superintendent to respond on the teacher
shortage business has responsed
20% Then it got it up at the high level
56%
that is very embarrassing and it's not
in conjunction with statutory law
they're required to report this but
there's no way of making sure that
occurs we don't have the staff to do
that and we don't have he doesn't have
the
hammer there is a resolution to that the
resolution of that is that if the state
provided more funding to local school
districts they could basically say if if
you don't return this back guess what
we're holding your your adequacy money I
I think they did that with the emergency
plans trying to get the emergency
PL
yeah yeah there's not a big stick that
the right that's unfortunate yeah
because there's places the state does
need
it so are we going to who's you're going
to write an amendment just to rpe out
the word comprehensive there so we have
it in our pocket okay thank and put on
type yeah committee
Amendment if everybody's good with that
if we have to go that route if we have
to go that route now if we have 306 come
in saying it's staying there I'm not so
sure we got to do anything I I think if
Pope's going to do it I don't think she
can put committee on it it'll go
committee when it when it gets voted by
the committee yeah I think have H well
she can do it then if you want to do it
hope go for it
okay and everybody else think about it
you know and hopefully we'll get a
response on the
n9th anything else yes any chance we can
get a hard copy of those new rigs when
those come out I know Jen's not here
today but or she's not here this
afternoon but well I you know I'm
concerned too because here they said we
took all that and put it back in I know
right and and so we're reading stuff
that's
ancient and it's lengthy so you really
need well for me I need a hard copy to
be able to note and Mark
and well after tomorrow if they're going
to make some decisions maybe we I'll
contact Nate and see if he will send us
where they are with their draft as of
that
that I st for
seem to be keeping very close to chest
yeah well them too yeah we're good
day